hello there you're watching the press
preview our first look at what's on the
front pages as they arrive
over the next half an hour we'll be
talking through the headlines with the
financial times's
whitehall editor sebastian payne and the
daily telegraph's assistant comment
editor olivia utley so a very good
evening to both you nice to see
so let's take a look at what's making
those front pages and the metro leads
with the
outrage stemming from facebook's
decision to block content from news
outlets on its platform in australia
after the social media giant objected to
a new law there that would force it
to pay content providers it's also the
lead story for the guardian which
focuses on accusations that the move is
undemocratic the daily mail hears
people as young as 40 who aren't
clinically vulnerable
or frontline workers could be given
their first dose of covid19 vaccine
by the end of march the daily telegraph
carries
promising news from a vaccine study
taking them to believe
to cut infection and transmission rates
by two-thirds
and the french president emmanuel macron
has spoken to the financial times
insisting that the u.s and richer
european nations should set aside up to
five percent of their vaccine supply to
send to poorer countries
so sebastian payne and olivia are ugly
here to go through some of these front
pages with me
and delivery you've picked out the daily
mail's front page first of all which has
an interesting headline it says over 40s
to get jabs by the end of march i mean
that's a lot
younger than we would expect and a lot
quicker than any kind of timetable we've
heard before
so so where does this come from
well so i think the quicker element it's
been it's been a bit strange actually in
recent days a lot of people have been
noting how
after having such an impressively quick
rollout for the first two months
the newsletter targets all actually
sounded quite unambitious
um so basically all this is saying that
if we if we keep going at the rate that
we're going at
then we should be finishing the next
band by the end of
march by the next month rather than
rather than by the end of may as it was
going to be
um so so that's the sort of speed
element then in terms of the priority
list element
there's been this discussion going on in
government for a while over
uh whether key workers should be bumped
up the
priority list ahead of um different age
groups so it's this question of whether
you know a thirty year old teacher or um
or a
45 year old big man should go ahead of
the the older group
they have decided against that and
sticking with the
age policy um which i think was
relatively predictable because at the
moment the government doesn't seem to be
linking
uh the vaccine rollout that closely
with uh the easing of lockdown and the
only purpose in sort of
getting key economic workers vaccinated
quickly would be if the government was
using the vaccine to ease lockdown
quickly
um so i think both elements of this
story are actually kind of
quite predictable um but of course it's
brilliant news that that we are going
fast enough to get
to over 40s to start being vaccinated in
the next couple of months
well i thought that's really encouraging
obviously um sebastian if
if that could be achieved what do you
make of the
the way that we're hearing about it here
on the front page and
the government has been cautious in its
estimates
up until now what do you make of the way
it's coming out and also this sense that
key workers may not be prioritized
well we've actually known that the jcvi
which is the independent committee that
decides who gets vaccinated when
they've always said that age has to be
the priority and in terms of professions
that's a question up for the government
and i think it's been reported and i've
certainly heard from
senior folks in whitehall that doing it
by profession is very complicated
and creating demarcations around certain
jobs is
difficult to do so they're going to
stick with age for the moment
this issue on when people get it is a
really fascinating one because at the ft
this week we did some number crunching
and we figured out that if you were to
maintain the level of 3 million jabs
that's the level we've had for the past
two weeks then all over 50s would have
one job by the end of
march now the government's target for
all over 50s is the end of april so that
means one of two things
one they're expecting a dip in supply
which would be quite concerning
but again people in governments are
saying that that that may happen maybe
some dips but they're not expecting a
big drop off
or two there's a lot of expectations
management going on here because we know
boris johnson has come acrop her many
times for
over promising and under delivering it
seems he's now flipped it round and is
under under promising and trying to over
deliver that so i think this daily mail
front page is just the sort of thing
downing she doesn't want to see
they don't want people getting far too
far ahead of themselves and excited
because that'll only increase the
demands for lockdown to ease
sooner but you know we saw another great
set of vaccination results today almost
half a million jabs
are delivered and if we keep up that
rate it's a very impressive thing and of
course
it's not just the pfizer and astrazeneca
vaccines we've got the novovax vaccine
and that will come online very soon
you've also got
the modern vaccine and the johnson
johnson vaccine
so really we should actually look at
increasing the rate of vaccinations
not just stabilizing it so i think my
view is ultimately
there might be some blips in supply but
fundamentally the government is just
trying to calm down expectations because
it doesn't want to rush that out of lock
down too easily if things do go wrong
he doesn't want to get the blame for it
as we saw when everything that went
wrong did go wrong pretty much in 2020.
well yes and i think most people would
agree
olivia wouldn't they that the the
vaccination rollout certainly to date
has been a success and the financial
times is interesting because they've got
an interview haven't they with the um
the french leader emmanuel macron
talking about
what those richer countries who do have
supplies of vaccines
at what stage they distribute them to
poorer countries because clearly the
point is
that the whole world needs to be
protected if we're going to stamp out a
pandemic
yeah absolutely and it's a very
admirable thing that making would like
to do here
um what's happening is that in african
countries
the vaccine is being sold through
intermediaries obviously uh companies
like astrazeneca
are giving the vaccine away at cost
price to um developing countries
but there are these intermediaries who
are hiking up the price meaning that
african countries are buying it
tend to be buying stocks and vaccines as
a higher price than europe
obviously that's not ideal in any way
and macron here is suggesting
that european countries should start
giving vaccine supplies to
um african countries and he said that
merkel here he's saying that merkel um
is on board with the plan in siri i
think
it's you know this is classic macron um
it's a very
statesmanlike gesture uh it's a very you
know
we europe can help out gesture um and
it's impressive
but i'm not sure if it's gonna go down
particularly well
in france um macron isn't that popular
in his own
country at the moment uh the rollout as
we know in europe has been
a bit of a disaster um and also he's got
this huge problem going on but in that
the french tend to be quite anti-vaxxer
and they've come very close to the
bottom
of every chart showing willingness to
get the vaccine so he's got that big
problem on his hands he's got a problem
on his hands that
that europe didn't get enough vaccines
in the first place they were complacent
about signing those deals and just
didn't get it over the line fast enough
so far behind us and rolled out um
and now he's offering to give away
vaccines which of course is admirable
and as you say necessary if we need to
stand because we need to stamp out the
pandemic worldwide for the vaccine to
work at all but
it'll be interesting to see how this
goes down domestically
well yes and uh from britain's point of
view the the guardian picks up on
what boris johnson is likely to say at
the upcoming
g7 summit the suggestion that
the uk could start to give away vaccines
at some point at what point is that
sebastian
well i think it's once the most
vulnerable have been vaccinated that is
in the uk the top nine groups which is
all over 50s all those extremely
clinically vulnerable and clinically
vulnerable as well
and as the uk government has said
several times that
once you vaccinate the top four groups
which we've now done
that should cut 88 percent of deaths
from covert 19
once you vaccinate the next five groups
you cut the an extra 11
but most crucially you ease net all the
pressure on the nhs and we've also seen
news this week of new drugs and new
medication coming on that really help
with the worst effects of covert 192. so
i think once you get past that point
when
you're saving lives with vaccinations
and the most
have been vaccinated then you do enter
this question of helping other countries
in that situation
a lot of people have warned about the
rise of vaccine nationalism and the idea
that countries will just hoard vaccines
for themselves and i think it's pretty
admirable but the boris johnson is
trying to get on the front foot here and
following
emmanuel macron's suggestion of saying
that you need to look to other countries
too
on this now obviously there will be a
backlash there will be people who will
say well we need to keep them all from
ourselves and more for
other countries but of course if you
look at what's going on in africa
those are countries that have very poor
health care systems they don't have
anywhere near the medication the testing
the ventilators
all the things that have helped us do
our best against this disease
but there's also a geopolitical element
we should mention as well that
china and russia are trying to roll out
their versions of covert vaccines which
haven't been approved by western
medical regulators very very quickly to
africa
and there's a big chance that if these
countries swoop in and they do very well
in rolling out their vaccines
that when it comes to future diplomatic
and political decisions
they're going to look to the countries
that gave them the vaccines that's
really at the core
of what boris johnson emmanuel macron
are saying tonight that it is the duty
of western countries to promote our
values and we do that through helping
with our medicine so i would imagine
from the uk's perspective
once we get past the first jabs for the
um for the
for those top nine groups which will be
somewhere between the end of march and
the end of april and i think this
question of distributing vaccines
will start to enter the form much more
quickly because of course hopefully by
that point we'll be exiting lockdown a
bit here too
interesting and and on that subject um
turning to the the metro
olivia um we've talked about uh
the pressure for lifting lockdown
restrictions we get the announcement
from the prime minister on monday
of course and today's figures on
infection rates and the drops are going
to
play in to that announcement
aren't they what's the metro telling us
about these figures
yeah um just story after story is
telling us and metro again here say
that the data basically couldn't really
be much better um infection rates down
by
80 percent um and then we've got
telegraph which
we're going to talk about soon which
shows that uh both our main vaccines to
help reduce
uh reduce transmission by up to
two-thirds that's much better than
anyone was expecting
um hospital admissions are already down
and will go down further there's
obviously cases like
um admissions lag behind cases
um so basically everything is going
exactly the direction we want it to go
and feel like i should be touching wood
here because uh
you know basically it couldn't be so
we're looking at we've got boris johnson
is there with his
thanks there boris johnson is there with
his
three different road maps for easing out
of lockdown that's what we're all
being heard that's what we're all being
briefed um
there's one extremely optimistic
scenario a mid-level scenario and a
pessimistic scenario and it's all going
to depend on this real life data
which is going to be coming in now and
over the weekend
so as we can see so far very quickly
which would imply that you know this
it's got to be this most positive
roadmap but the data is still coming in
it's a very very
fluid live situation and i don't think
even boris is going to know right up
until sort of
monday morning exactly what the roadmap
is going to say
indeed and today's data appears to show
that the lockdown is certainly having an
effect
it's not clear whether the vaccine is
having an impact on those figures or not
but there is this front page story
on the telegraph sebastian we really
haven't got very much time to talk about
it but but
tell us what you can briefly about it
so public health england has been doing
this big study into how
covered vaccines cut transmission
because we know they develop antibodies
we know they help stopping serious
illness
but for getting out of lockdown you've
got to cut down transmission
and there's some very good initial data
for the pfizer vaccine from israel
the telegraph's front page says the phe
study which is
landing on boyce johnson's desk tonight
shows similarly good results and as
olivia just said
if this is born out by the full data the
prime minister receives
then we should be on a pretty good
trajection for getting out of lockdown
quite quickly because the vaccines will
stop illness
but crucially stock transmission of
covert 19 too so fingers crossed
this is born out and the vaccinations
just keep on going
well indeed i think a fingers toes
everything crossed
but we'll get no information until
monday will we but um
we're going to take a break right there
lots to talk about coming up after the
break including
is facebook being undemocratic by
banning news outlets in australia we'll
be talking about that
next you're watching the press preview
with me tonight sebastian payne and
olivia utley
and sebastian we're turning to the front
page of the guardian next because their
main story focuses on
facebook they say that they're under
fire
and accused they say in the sub-head of
trying to bully a democracy with a block
on news site so talk us through it
so um the australian government's led by
um the
right-wing leader scott morrison it's
about introducing legislation
that would force social media companies
to strike deals with news publishers
this all comes back to
the issue that um all advertising
revenues basically gone out of print
um publications and into digital places
like google
facebook twitter instagram you name it
and so this law is making its way
through
the australian parliament at the moment
and i think google has struck a deal
with news and news corporation for
example
in australia but facebook has i think to
use the technical term thrown its toys
out of the pram here
they decide to block all news content on
facebook in australia so that's 18
million australians
who use facebook now can't read any news
content
at all and this has been attacked widely
by politicians in the uk
in canada in australia as well and it's
saying that facebook is using bully boy
tactics because it doesn't want to
strike these deals facebook in return
says that this law
put forward by the morrison government
as a fundamental misunderstanding of its
business model
this all comes to a clash that all
countries are facing with in terms of
the power of these big tech companies
there's some big anti-trust
cases set to start in america that could
lead
to facebook how to divest some of its
properties like whatsapp like instagram
for example with that feeling
they've got too much power and they're
trying to overrun the democratic wishes
of people i think when you look at
what's happened australia
those fears might be borne out by a
little bit of reality there but i don't
think this has done
social networks reputation any good
whatsoever well yes and i suppose we
shouldn't be surprised olivia that
newspapers take a dim view the front
page of the metro as well
delete facebook is their headline there
but
what do you think the implications are
presumably there'll be countries around
the world watching what's going on in
australia because
this kind of this battle and this
debate about freedom of information is a
big one
yeah um i think it's really interesting
what australia's done here
personally i think the australian
government was quite brave and sensible
to do this because
the stone on big tech has basically been
profiting off newspapers while
newspapers
um sync so you know offering free
content from newspapers
online not paying the newspapers for
that content and profiting off that
content it doesn't seem fair
at all but i completely see it looks
pretty petty
of facebook to have done this um but i
actually completely see why
they've done it from their perspective
because facebook is now fighting quite a
lot of different battles on different
fronts they've got this
you know giving people news for free is
is a big part of their business model
that's under thresh over in australia
and will be around the world soon
um then there's question of whether
whether or not they're a publisher of a
platform whether or not they're
responsible for the content on their
page
the fact that they banned donald trump
suggests they are responsible for the
content that goes on that page but if
you're
saying that and you're opening a pretty
big can of worms because obviously there
aren't enough facebook employees to
monitor
what every single person on facebook is
saying every day so they're fighting a
lot of battles on different fronts and
they're desperately trying to win them
all
so i do see why they push up and fight
against this but from an
outsider's perspective it just looks
terrible it seems like
classic evil being attacked because not
only did they block
australians from seeing the news they
also got them from seeing sort of
government announcements about things
like forest fires
and in this story here in the garden
there's uh there's a place where
domestic abuse helps sites was taken
down by facebook
okay um it doesn't look good indeed well
we must leave it there
for now but olivia and sebastian always
good to get your take on things thanks
very much indeed